5 25 on your Wednesday one of us driving
you crazy well a viewer email asks a
familiar question
Iris writes during the afternoon Rush
Hour the carpool lane on the Northbound
95 from Rancho to Ann Road is full of
single drivers speeding past the other
traffic what are they going to get the
nhp out there to give these folks
tickets for one driving alone in a
carpool lane and two speeding it doesn't
make any sense to have a carpool lane if
no one adheres to the law
all righty Iris Nevada State Police have
said in the past that Troopers enforce
the HOV law when they see violations but
that they're often too busy dealing with
crashes or impaired drivers but I'll
forward your email just in case they
might have a different response and
thanks for writing in buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com